اسال الناس على الفيديو الاب الذي يحضر
الحليب لابنه في مجلس الرجال ما تعليقكم
على هذا المشهد
[موسيقى]
في حياتي انه في اب مثل هذا الاب ما شاء
الله تبارك الله الله يحميهم انه وقته
ومجهود وشغله يعني حتى في عز انشغاله ما
شاء الله معطي وقت وبيساعد المراه في في
هذا الوقت يعني صراحه اقدر هذا الشيء
واتمنى من الجميع ان يشوف هذا المشهد
وياخذه بطريقه ايجابيه
يعني مو مهم المكان قد ما يهم الولد اللي
ما يبكي ويصيح هو يموت لا ما يهم المكان
في اي مكان كان الاول اخيره الولد هذا
جيعان ولا يبغى يبكي ولا يسوي شيء فعلشان
كذا لازم نوفره الاكل وبيت السعاده الولد
تصرف من اب حكيم جدا انا الولد جلس يرضى
بالمره يعلمه يعني يغطي احتياجات الطفل
ويجلس في مجالس الرجال من هو صغير
انه ممكن يصير معي هذا الموقف اكيد
[موسيقى]
شيء ممتاز جدا يعني بمثل عن صوره الرجل
العربي عن التعامل مع الطفل والتعامل مع
ال ال العائله
اتوقع انه مثل عن تربيته وتربيه عائلته
الكريمه الطيبه
حنان الاب بشكل واضح جدا ويمكن ده جزء من
المشاعر دائما ما بتبقاش ظاهره للمجتمع ان
الاب ممكن يظهر الحنيه دي ولكن كان تصرف
جميل وهمم فيديو يعني حاسس ان الواحد
مشتاق لاولاده يعني اب راح وحلوه كويس
وهمم ما فيش اي اختلاف يعني هو بيكسب ثقه
الطفل انه العمر
شيء جميل جدا